oh discouraged by the pandemic
two-time corporate justly champions and
foreign in this online era
will any team rise to the occasion and
knock them off their hearts
find out
[Music]
oh hello there welcome to the 2020
season of the corporate chess league i'm
alex kirford
founder of the corporate chess league
financial advisor and team captain
of edward jones we are so happy
that you are making the adjustment to
virtual
online corporate chess league this year
and
so happy to have more teams more players
and more
competition when we started out the
corporate chess league
we desired to have an opportunity for
networking
enjoyment of the game of chess and being
able
to come together and compete as
different companies glad that you're
here with us
today and looking forward to more games
to come
thank you alex welcome players to the
third installment of the corporate chess
league
in this historic 2020 season each
corporation will play
two matches and each player will play
two games
per match for a total of four games
tonight
if your corporation wins the match your
team will receive an additional
20 points for every win you'll receive
two grand prix points as well every
point counts
because on december 17th the highest
scoring four corporations
will be invited to the final four to
play for
all the glory here's how we get started
please open your google sheet
and uh player one please
press the challenge button
this will take you to chess.com
live now you'll see in this
time box here it's listed at 10 minutes
with no delay no increment just 10-0 but
in case
uh it's not on that setting right now
just click on it
press more and then click on 10 minutes
okay and then make sure that you are
challenging the correct person
their name will uh appear right there
and then
rated it is not going to be rated so
just click this button
over to swipe it to the uh swipe it to
the right
make sure that the green is off
all right and now you're ready to play
this is crucial just
press the play button one time and be
patient
if you would click it multiple times uh
you'll be paired with a random person
so uh just make sure that you just
challenge one time
and then player two please accept it in
a timely fashion
and then you're off to the races and
once you're done with game one
be sure to rematch cheers
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay
safe and continue to watch play and
enjoy the game of chess
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
hello we are live in studio b of the
saint louis chess club welcome one and
all to the third installment
of the corporate chess league all right
today hey everybody please log on to
chess.com live if you have not logged in
there yet
please log in now because that's the
only way you can accept
or give challenges all right but we got
some matches today
and uh let's check out the the standings
right now
edward jones they just keep on winning
and winning and winning
they have accumulated 123 and a half
points wwt worldwide technology
is not playing tonight so they probably
will not remain in second place
when this night is concluded so you guys
can uh
either take first or second tonight and
uh and climb your way up the standings
ascension is a standing strong with 56
and a half points
merits is right behind with 52 points
only the top four scoring teams will
make it to the final four
on december 17 2020 so
uh so every point counts tonight
then we got express scripts with 49
followed by
enterprise with 38 and a half bear with
38
and dora tree with 17 and a half
points so we got some great matches
tonight hopefully we'll get started
uh pretty soon we'll have to wait for uh
nick risco to say the word though
let's check out some matches tonight
we got in round one we'll have
edward jones playing express scripts
and these are all brand new matches so
uh
these teams have not competed against
each other
in the 2020 season now we have
enterprise playing dortry
bear against ascension that should be a
great match
and then merits gets the first round by
so they automatically have 10 points
right now
but if they score 2 out of 3 2 and a
half out of 3
or 3 out of 3 they will get a bonus 10
points
plus you get a point for every
additional win you get as well
so a lot of points up for grabs tonight
you get that additional 20 points
if you win your match
and uh remember it's back-to-back
matches
so when you are finished with game one
please issue a rematch and it's very
important when you make that
initial challenge as i was saying in the
uh
the initial uh video gearing up to this
broadcast
uh when you do issue a challenge just
issue it
one time just press it one time because
if you
keep pressing the the challenge button
you will
actually get paired with a random
opponent on chess.com
so please only when you when you issue
this challenge just press it one time
please
all right and we got some exciting
players too tonight
of course the founder of the uh corvette
chess league
alex corford will be playing for edward
jones tonight
so that should be uh that should be fun
he will be playing
board number three
the shawl will be playing board number
one
vishal was a long time uh st louis chess
club member
all the way back in the uh in the arts i
guess you call it like in 2008 2009
yeah he was there he was there from from
almost day one i of course
if you guys don't know me my name is uh
mike cummer i'm an international arbiter
and of course state chess champion
scholastic
1998 and um and i've been here since
fortunate enough to be here
since day one so we just celebrated our
12 year anniversary july 17th
uh 2020 so so it's been a lot of fun
and then jd will actually be playing
board one
for uh for edward jones so
congratulations
and of course we got john boyer time
boyer uh playing on uh
enterprise leading them in this uh
in this round so so that should be fun
we got some great teams tonight
and it should be a great uh check out
the uh
the youtube comments see if anybody's
if anybody is watching or uh playing or
johnny b bonnie g
i i just looked i already did a shout
out for you all right cool
i assume that's john b on there
all right so uh let's see let's see what
we get hopefully everybody is logging
into
uh chess.com live i'm gonna start uh
following you guys so we can uh
so we can see some uh some games here so
uh
pardon me for just a second while i uh
type in some uh some players names and
uh hopefully
i can start following you i could watch
your games like
unfortunately alex is still offline so
i'm not able to follow
alex just yet
all right remember you guys have to be
on chess.com live it's very important
if you're just in chess.com like they're
just normal site if you're not on
chess.com
live you will not be able to to
give or receive the challenges so so
that's paramount if you guys
aren't in there yet
all right let's see if i can follow this
guy yeah he's offline too
all right all right nick risco you got
to be telling them hey
get online here get online or else this
thing will never start we're we're
we're within four minutes of starting
the third installment
of the corporate chess league
so let's see if we get uh we got anybody
else
see if we got anybody else here
all right let's check out uh
merits is a board one he claims he's an
international master international
master rounder so
look out for this guy look out for this
guy let's check it out
he is also offline all right we got
three minutes to get everybody on
chess.com that is more important
than being on uh
the google meet right now all right
i'll be back in two minutes
do
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey we are back live and we got some
games to show
we have a ascensions board one
mr nick rigon playing eagle eye
two two two zero zero one
can you see the the screen ben simon
yeah
all right and uh so here we go
so all right we got we're on board
uh nick has a minute 20 left and his
his uh opponent is in serious time
pressure
the gentleman eagle eye is a
bear's number one seed here so this is a
battle of the board ones can uh
can eagle i get a get this attack going
he's got his rooks doubled up on the h
file heading down toward the h pawn
oh and mr ragon the rook is now
protecting the pawn he's coming he's
going to try to get into h3
quick and see see what he can do
but it might be too little too late but
we'll see all right he's
doubled up as rooks on the second rank
to protect the pawn
and the queen goes back it's going to be
really tough with 18 seconds left to win
it
can nick just run him out of time
oh now he's got a threat all right here
comes queen e6 check
all right the king's moving away
and the queen goes back he's probably
gonna reroute with a check to on b3
all right but he's going with the pawns
just keep pushing the pawns okay here we
go
see what sticks here
all right queen's attacking a7 for the
check
there he goes oh without that queen
there's no way he's going to be able to
checkmate him
four seconds three seconds
and every time you pre-move on chess.com
you lose one
tenth of one second so you can't just
pre-move yourself to victory
he's gotta check and he's out of time
big win for uh
for nick ragone so ascension is now
up one nothing so let's see uh some
other games going on here
let's go with uh the founder of the uh
corporate just league alex corford
he is playing with the black pieces
against
n burdek
and this is the this is their board
three between edward jones and express
scripts
alex crawford has a massive rating
advantage
1742 chess.com
blitz rating compared to
1095 but but these ratings really don't
mean much because
they might not actually be playing that
often on chess.com
or their account could be dormant for a
long time so
it might not reflect their true strength
because it looks like
uh they're pretty toe to toe right now
if you're scoring at home it's uh four
to four
right now
so what is he up to with his knight on
b4
okay he was he was threatening a fork on
c2
to get the the rooks
but he moved his knight out of the way
so now his queen is protecting the c2
square so it's not allowing the knight
to get in here because if the knight
would go
it would get captured so now what
what's the plan then what's the plan for
so
alex could just push oh he's going there
anyway oh because the bishop
the bishop was protecting it the square
interesting so now
so now this guy is uh he's in trouble so
what could have he
have done differently maybe he just
needed to move his rook
just out of the way and that way he
wouldn't have fallen for the fork
interesting we do have a result
moneyballin
has won moneyballin was playing
for let's check out who
moneyballin was playing for he was
playing for enterprise
so now he is 1-0 so enterprise is on the
board
with one point and uh
he used his uh rooks doubled them up and
got a great uh
mating combination so congratulations to
moneyballin
let's check out uh vishal's game
vishal has won his first game on board
one
against kamuni and um
so this is match number two for
uh v shawl let's see how he's doing the
computer has him
plus two right now on the scoreboard
maybe not in the evaluation
so let's check out so he's got a couple
more pawns but
but his opponent very good
rated solid 18
is uh is forking the pawns at this
moment he's a
he's attacking the a pawn and the b pawn
simultaneously vishal's going for the
checkmate he is going for the checkmate
on g2
so let's check out how uh camuni's gonna
deal with this
it's not so easy oh and that's not
oh it's check okay it's check it's check
so the king is in check here
so uh he's he's got to take it
what's funny he can take it with the
rook let's see if he can
see it let's see if michelle can see it
he can just take with the rook that's my
guess
oh but it's not it's not good because
queen takes
check so it's too cute of a move it's
too cute of a move
interesting so tactics are all over this
board and that's what you would expect
is this is a board one for edward jones
and express scripts
vishal expert on uh
chess.com maybe even in reality too
there it is
but correct my guess is correct rook
takes d5
i don't know if it's gonna work though i
don't know if it's going to work so he's
got
check and then the king will have to get
out of dodge he actually only has one
legal move in this position
and that's king h7 and wisely pre-moved
oh so now it's going to be very
interesting if he tries to defend with
rook here
guess what rook takes and the game is
going to be lights out
so vishal with the win
yeah and what's so sad it's
kamuni he was down by or two the whole
game and now he's plus one but
that's why the scoreboard really doesn't
matter in chess it's whoever gets the
king wins you know
so yeah this is this is not going to be
good
for kamuni i mean his best bet is
actually queen takes
bishop i mean that's that's the only way
to avoid getting checkmated in uh
in one move and actually that's not too
bad
because when you take you're going to
play rook takes rook
so this is interesting
so now vishal shawl well the computer
has it all tied up
one two three four five
and the queen is worth nine so 14.
the rooks are worth five each so that's
ten so it's tied up fourteen fourteen
but this passer past
pawn is a is a killer it looks like
but we'll see this is this is what we
like to see in a
for our board one match up we do have
another result on the board
king kingtaker1234 was victorious he got
this nice uh
queen uh checkmate assisted by his pawns
and so
he gets on the board for his team
edward jones so edward jones currently
is
up two nothing this is uh
there's four games in this edward jones
express
scripts uh matches four members so
they'll play a total of
eight games in in this round so if you
get to uh four and a half points
you get the additional 20 points
so let's check it out let's go back to
uh vishal's game here
and c so he's going to push the pawn
again
and then he can get right behind the
pawn okay so he just gave that pawn up
to win that pawn
which makes sense
so this is the live position now he's
got
he's got two uh michelle now
he gave up his one passer on the e file
in the center of the board to get to uh
two pass pawns but with these rooks just
harassing this queen
this could go on for a while there is a
there is a
a rule in chess if you go 50 moves
without a pawn move or a capture
it will be declared a draw and chess.com
will just automatically declare it or
draw nobody has to make that claim or
anything
on the server they'll just say it's been
50 moves without a pawn move
or uh our capture and they'll just
declare
a draw but it looks like vishal is uh
pushing the pawns and now he's got a
check
so uh oh and that he he he said enough
oh he must have got uh yeah
so so the reason why uh vishal won
is uh it was a fork
the queen was attacking the king and the
rook simultaneously
lights out game over so that was a good
good one by
nichole he took got two points
uh for his team but a hard-fought game
by a
community that's for sure josh fidel
here
and uh presenting you with the gm
looks like eagle eye
got his revenge uh so i am ready and
they tied that up
1-1 see some more uh
some more results coming in here
also for bear
it looks like uh
ascension one dave
dave was victorious in this one
as a bio proto up by five
points unfortunately ran out of time so
we'll give a
a win for dave here
let's check out some more action oh
there's john boyer
he is playing with the black pieces
against the wizzy and john won the first
game
in their match
i don't want to give away all of john
boyer's secrets but
he does like to play the alekhine's
defense so if you play e4
against john the king's pawn up too he's
going to
he's going to counter with his knight
knight to f6 go giving
instant pressure to the opponent itself
so be on the lookout for that if you're
playing uh john in round number two
all right so what's going on okay so he
got his queen out
of there out of the pin his knight was
temporarily pinned but now it's out
john looks like he is comfortably up by
one point and look he's practically
doubling his opponent's rating so
so let's check out uh let's go back to
alex crawford's game this is this is
heating up
alex is a plus two it looks like
uh it's getting down to the nitty-gritty
here
so it looks like alex is up in exchange
from that
that fork that we saw earlier when uh he
played knight to c2 and took
took one of one of one of the rooks
and uh and now he
he's pretty much he's pretty solid uh
so if i have 23 seconds left 22 you know
what i'm trying to do i'm just trying to
go for uh some kind of crazy checkmate
here
like push these pawns and just see what
see see what happens
oh and that's going to be the final
because after pawn takes
the queen is hanging and
and it's not going to be good it's not
going to be good
so he'll uh he'll run out of time
and then we'll so we'll give alex the
win for
edward jones here edward jones a very
dominant
team in the uh corporate chess league as
we see and they did an instant rematch
let's see if we can get this game
rolling right away and there we go
okay good yeah so right when you're
finished with the uh
with your game yeah instant rematch here
great
check out uh kingtaker1324
he is playing for uh edward jones as
well
and so yeah he won his first match let's
see how he's doing
tonight he is now plus two it looks like
king taker with edward jones is playing
for uh
edward jones against neil
from express scripts
and uh so basically the only difference
in this game really is and it
is a king taker has uh
more pawns but there goes one pawn
the queen takes e6 with check
so let's see how he's going to deal with
that he got gets out of the check
and now he's got these two dangerous
past pawns
as varkobian would say push the puns
so maybe he'll just push him up
let's see that's my guess
and we have another result on the board
oh there it is
d5 was actually played threatening of
course d6 here
and he's going from there it's a very
dangerous time
for uh neil here he's gotta gotta find a
way to break up these pawns
if he can actually sacrifice his bishop
for these two pawns
probably wouldn't be a bad idea if he if
he gets the chance
let's check back on uh john boyer's game
he's he's plus one so he's got a
comfortable advantage
because really it's nothing's really
going on too much in this position
that uh like
white's not really generating any any
threats so john is up a pawn and has a
very very comfortable
position let's check back on uh
on dave here against bioprodu ryo proto
had
a huge advantage oh and and there there
it is we have a
we have a checkmate on the board it
looks like
wow you don't see that very often that
white's king marches
all the way down to the uh
to the final final row that's really not
where you want to be
unless you're uh you're trying to help
out a pawn
become a queen uh yeah some
so he got his
revenge so they're they're tied up 1-1
so bio-proto gets on the board
for bear
let's check out uh alex herford's game
for edward jones it looks like he is
plus one
and he's got a pass pawn too okay so
that's it's kind of
the theme of the night is uh get those
get those past pawns because they're
they're deadly they are
deadly if you can get them oh and it's a
it's a
it's a bye-bye rook
let's see if he takes it that's the
guess but then
then he will get the he will get the
knight though so
he gets something for something at least
but i don't think it's gonna be
enough
what is he thinking about
all right he
alex is still actually thinking about it
that that that is not uh that is not
alive this is not the live position just
so you know
alex is still contemplating taking the
the rook and he has eventually has but
of course
he'll get the uh he'll get the knight
for it so he's still in the game
temporarily here
but then alex should just calmly retreat
his queen and he did the f3
excellent and now he's got a very solid
position
he has plus three and most likely on his
way
to victory
let's check out a king taker's game
he won his first game and he is plus two
right now
and he's got those two dangerous past
pawns but i think oh and if he takes
unfortunately it will be a fork
so a fork is a double attack so uh
king taker1324 will be attacking both
simultaneously so he cannot take
this pawn it's a poison pawn as they
call it let's check out the chat real
quick see if anybody's talking round one
just started all right
17 players watching now okay welcome one
and all
and uh let's let's see some more games
we do have a result here
if we haven't uh vindi
with uh
vindy with uh bear went
2 and 0 against his opponent so uh
chalk up some more victories for bear
two more
okay so this is going to be very very
difficult for
uh the wizzy to hold this
against john
so he's got yeah yeah this this pawn is
going to be
tough to stop
and then john can just push the pawn
and this should be a pretty pretty easy
victory for uh
for john boya class a player
and chess.com chess
let's expert back on alex's game he is
now plus four
not too much going on in that one
can king take a one three two four
hold on to this lead so he has plus two
he does not want to trade his knight for
the bishop interesting
and but he's got to really watch out
because even though he is
he's up you know those two past pawns he
is still
in the danger zone of getting back row
check made it and he's going to try it
he's going to try it
so if uh if he takes guess what
check mate so you do not want to be back
row checkmated
so there's different ways he could play
this
he could play
this is just a guess this is not this is
not the live this is not the live
board the live board is this position
right here
so uh so right so the way the way he got
out of it was very smart
this is a very very interesting way he
got out of this he plays g3
so what's the difference between g3 and
h3
here in
in this position if he would play h3 in
this position
neil could put his bishop on f4 and
still
threaten the checkmate not allowing
white's king to escape
so after a while they did he did do some
trades he got another check-in
but uh he's pretty safe
all right he's attacking the rook but
but yep you just got to keep playing
i mean just try just try for the win
neil also has ideas of maybe playing
rook to b2
followed by bishop to e3
followed by rook takes f2 check
just pile on this f2 square
so he's got some ideas
round two will start
when nick risco says it well so so we
we are yeah we are we are getting a lot
of uh
results in quickly here
the time control is game 10 with no
delay
no increment
so let's see and king king taker he's
got a
he's got a minute 24 to win it well neil
has
one minute
and that's it he get a queen and he wins
it's that easy
all right so king taker is now
2-n-o
we might have well we don't know how jd
did but
but they could be going for a sweep
right now
is this is this the live standings ben
simon
okay so this is as live as it gets and
remember this does not
take to account the 20 bonus
points that each team
receives merits
already did get their 10 points though
that that has been
uh updated it looks like
edward jones is going for the sweep
of express scripts if
if alex can hold on to the lead he is
only currently
plus one right now
you do not get extra bonus points for uh
sweeping though
you do get so the way the scoring works
in the corporate just league
every time you win as a as a team member
you get one point added to your team's
score
if you win the match the the entire
match
you get 20 bonus points so if
uh if alex can hold on for the win here
they'll get the 20 bonus points they got
that in their pocket
and then they'll get eight points so
they end up with 28 points because
they had four team members and every one
of them
uh won and that does not count the extra
games
that are that are happening as well
outside of the uh the match play
so let's see what how alex can can do
this
oh he's gonna he's gonna check him right
up here probably
i would imagine that looks pretty
powerful
so that's and my guess is correct this
is the live
the live position edward jones going for
the sweep
according to my standings
all standings are to be determined but
but that's what it looks like
so far
oh i i would have played h4 if i was
alex because then i i have dreams of a
queen to g5 check maybe and plus i'm
and then i would not be allowing the
king to go
escape to uh g5 as well
not that he probably really wants to
anyway i mean
if if i was uh maybe i just play g5 here
and see what's going on
try to get any counter play i can and
notice you do not want to play queen
takes b6
because it hangs your queen it's
protected by the the queen here
so h3 is played g5 has been cancelled so
they do that the chess.com does not even
like that suggestion
he's not going to play that so so let's
check out
how he plays okay
yeah how is alex going to break through
maybe queen to c6 here
followed by queen to c8 that's an idea
i don't know if it's a good idea but
it's something because
this oh but checks are always fun though
right
i love putting my opponent in check so
i'll give him another check
he's got to he's got to
round two should start at 7 15 according
to
uh the tournament director nick risco
big shout out to nick risco for putting
this all together it's like
it's a tough and and updating all the uh
the standings and it's a
it's a it's a big task let's just say
but we're happy to do it and this is a
a great fun event and i hope everybody's
having fun and
and cheers and cheers
and uh having some fun here tonight
but we should be able to start right at
7 15 i would imagine
uh maybe maybe nick can tell me what
what that what
what the what that match is
well
let's let's ask nick to see if uh
that way we can follow that game to the
bitter end ben simon
so we so there is there is a
mystery game going on
so okay okay so he's got the queen to c6
check and then let's see
so after uh after he moves his king
maybe he will get the queen to c8
in
and that might be that might be the end
and that might be the sweep
edward jones that never lows they never
lose they take they take the corporate
chess league very seriously and uh
good for them all right and alex found
the he found the maneuver that
our my my idea that i was uh putting out
there
after after he gave him a couple checks
just just for good measure
just for fun so that that should be the
end of the game i i don't i don't see
how
rook takes doesn't work because
well then he can just play rook takes
check and then everything falls and he's
just up a queen queen takes obviously
doesn't work because
pawn takes and then he gets a queen
there's just nothing
nothing he can really do about it
there's no good offense
okay so we do have a game going on
between
10 john and tom deere
it looks like fair and ascension
has drawn their match
and and the reason why bear has uh more
points is because they played they
brought more
players and got some uh extra
uh extra games in that were worth
you know ultimately two points one one
for each round
we we play back-to-back matches as
everybody knows in the
corporate chess league okay so let's go
uh well let's see the the triumphant end
of uh of alex's game and then we'll go
to uh
the tom deere match
will we be taking a short break after uh
after the games
okay and alex won he completed the sweep
so congratulations to edward jones
keeping the their dominance alive
but they do have a tough match next
round against ascension
so that that's going to be uh
that's going to be something else
it's going to be one to follow for sure
all right so let's check out uh
let's check out the final match of uh of
round
number one
here we go
where did it
well it doesn't look like they're
they're playing anymore so it looks like
all the games
have been concluded
so we probably will take a a quick break
here
let me just look at one more thing here
let's see if we can find this game real
quick
and go from there
it looks like it looks like this has
been concluded we will be
back uh in about 10 minutes probably ben
simon
and uh and we'll have the live action
of round two
of the corporate justly
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value
chess brings to our community in these
times of social distancing it's more
important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube
and twitch channels we're also holding
tournaments and private lessons online
from the comfort of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play enjoy the game of chess
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
game review
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay
safe and continue to watch play and
enjoy the game of chess
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community
in these times of social distancing it's
more important than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online through our
youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online from the comfort
of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay
safe and continue to watch play and
enjoy the game of chess
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
welcome back to round two of the third
installment
of the corporate chess league it seems
like these games are going to get
started
a little bit earlier so as soon as nick
risco says the word
please start the matches but not before
then
okay but what what a great great matches
we have today and five teams
still have a legitimate chance to win
tonight
and move up in that uh the grand prix
standings and remember
you get 20 extra points for a win 10 for
a tie
bear already they got to buy
uh in this round so they already have an
additional 10 points
so really you could pencil them in at 26
right now
tied with enterprise if they win that
match
they will receive an additional 10
points plus
plus a point for every win they get so
they could get up to
uh because they have six people
they could get an additional 12 points
so so look at that edward jones right on
top
enterprise right behind him
enterprise will be playing express
scripts while edward jones will be
playing
ascension so ascension if they if they
come up big against edward jones
they could end up as the number one team
tonight
and merits hats off the merits they they
initially got their
uh 10 points with the buy in round one
but but they didn't want it they wanted
they wanted the full
20 and they got it and so they got the
uh 24 points so
so congratulations to merits and we are
off
it looks like all these games have uh
have started so let's get right down
to it let's uh let's actually start with
uh
we didn't really get to see uh
jd's games from last time around
he will be playing ascension's board one
nick ragone nick ragone started with the
white
pieces so let's see how jd does
this should be a very competitive game
and a big match for edward jones
somebody's got to put them to the test
and i think ascension
is just the team to do it
so let's check this out okay so so no
fireworks yet
let's go to uh we didn't get to see tom
dear's uh
match from uh from last time he is also
with uh enterprise
tom deere is playing with the black
pieces here
so it's tied up 4-4
oh but he played the dreaded f6 move
never play f6 but sometimes
sometimes it's warranted
so oh he's going he's going for the
attack here
and oh and so that is this pawn is under
attack
so this the position just screams
g5 here it's screaming g5
oh that must have been a a mouse slip a
mouse lip is very
unfortunate in in the game of chess but
maybe it's a sacrifice
you never know but he wanted that pawn
he's like the heck with that bishop
because actually if pawn takes pawn
takes
this h file would be open
so you never know but if he could
somehow jump over that uh
f6 pawn he could uh he could play there
so so now he's going to take the bishop
he's not afraid
so okay so okay now g5 now g5
let's let's uh let's check out uh
enterprises board one
john boyer chess.com
blitz expert let's see
they have a night for a night
john boyer actually prefers to play with
the black pieces because then he can
bring out his alakine defense so let's
check
this out let's go back to uh let's go
around the board here let's see uh money
balling
bowling he got he got a a good win
last time for enterprise
and he is plus one
oh buddy oh but he's got he's got the
pin on this knight here
is there really i don't think he might
he might not have a way to protect this
because the rook is bearing down on the
knight
and so is the bishop
who else can help defend it i don't
think anybody can so
so express grips once they get on that
board and win some games and
and this this is looking very good for
uh
for express scripts here king taker yeah
i had a feeling it was just going to
take when when
times are tough you just want to take
stuff yeah but unfortunately he should
just
take back he could he could just take
rook takes knight right now
or no he can't no he can't the queen is
under attack
so he needs to play queen takes f6 or
knight takes f6
right away probably knight takes f6 is
pretty good because in case
uh moneyballing can find a way to uh to
protect this knight
he can jump in with the knight and uh
and and get him good
it just it when yeah when when when
pieces are pinned
just find a way to attack them attack
pin pieces don't capture them
until you're going to get a payoff but
it looks like you're going to get a
payoff because you're just going to win
the night
all right king taker one three two four
see what he's up to they're tied 4-4
according to the scoreboard
king taker1234 is playing for edward
jones
in their big match against ascension
it's for first place but there's other
teams other teams are still in it
i mean five teams could could could end
up number one
at the end of this uh at the end of this
night to take the third installment home
obviously you'll take a bunch of grand
prix points
and the glory but it doesn't assure you
to get into the final four
that's what everybody's gearing for and
hopefully
a portion of that maybe
maybe live in the chess club wouldn't
that be
awesome december 17th so but you gotta
you gotta finish in the top
four
of the total grand prix so let's check
it out
so what is going on let's see if uh
money ballin ended up
getting the he did he ended up getting
the knight for free
or end up losing the night unfortunately
oh we got ryan chester
club manager
he is playing with the white pieces
against vindy
so vindi is playing for a bear
so bear wants that i mean they're still
they're still theoretically in this
if they can if they can get that extra
10 points
uh and win some games they could end up
with a high number
uh tonight as well so this one's all
tied up
night for night oh but
ryan's got this bishop way back there
pinning the f pawn so see if there's any
tactics
in the future with that one all right
but let's check back in
on uh board one of of
ascension versus edward jones
ooh oh we got we got the we got the uh
the two rooks against the queen again so
the queen
the queen won in vishal's game
because uh because his opponent
in round one uh didn't keep his rooks
connected the whole time
and he got uh forked unfortunately so
let's see if
in a frank's tt end game
uh of course uh nick regon let's see how
nick rigon
tries to win with the queen
and he's got some passers but but
according to the scoreboard it's all
tied up
these rooks are worth ten and the queen
is worth nine but there goes another
pawn
so nick can uh add
add up some points here hopefully
my guess queen takes a7
oh no no no i do not want to guess that
i do not want to guess that
look at what's happening he's he's
threatening a perpetual check here so
so yeah so so nick needs to keep his uh
his queen protecting this pawn
because i think with the c pawn he
should be able to
he'll have the advantage if he can trade
off the queen
for the two rooks even if it costs them
this pawn in the long run
but then jd will have a pass pawn
end games are tough i used to pretend i
was the master
of the end game but it was just by luck
you win some of these things
but uh yeah queen takes a7 yeah i better
be incorrect
so what did he end up playing he he
ended up playing king to h1
a lot lots of happened so he got the
check king h1
rook gets behind the pawn so he's
threatening checkmate either rook can
deliver the checkmate here
oh the two rooks are going to prevail
you can't stop the checkmate
it's over
so jd with the win
for uh edward jones they just keep
winning they just keep winning
a tough one that was a
tough one all right let's see some uh
let's see uh the founder of the uh
corporate chess league let's see what
alex is up to here oh
unfortunately alex lost his
uh his first match against dave
so we have a 0-1
but let's see if alex can get revenge in
round two of match 2
against dave
yeah alex is having none of it look look
at this he wants
he wants to uh to just crush
and so this is the live position
i have a feeling alex is just going to
take with well
he might take with check with the bishop
or or yeah that was the other
alternative but now after pawn takes you
get queen takes
and maybe maybe alex can get
just get a perpetual check when you when
you repeat the same position
three times in chess whether it's
perpetual or not
if you see the same position three times
in the game it's a draw
and the computer will declare as such oh
interesting
but he just got his king out of the pin
and so now alex has turned the tables he
is now plus
one he's got a rook and two pawns which
equals seven
to uh a knight in a bishop which are
each worth three so
in theory and the scoreboard has uh alex
plus one
and let's see if he wants the queen
trade
he'll let hill he'll trade the queens
if he wants but so now dave can trade
the queens but then
his knight will be hopping out
very interesting a very interesting game
all right let's check on uh our good
friend
john boyer time boyer he's playing with
the white pieces against uh
kimone who was playing very well
in a round one
as for his the board one of uh
express script so enterprise is his
enterprise uh john boyer
uh board one for enterprise with the
white pieces against kamuni
board one for express groups so
he'll oh he's got the check
and then he's gonna pick up the bishop
so it looks like john
even though he's under the three minute
mark
is this game 10 with uh no delay no
increment
and that's it that's checkmate wow he
didn't even want to take the uh
hey if you see checkmate you better play
it see the win take the win
so uh we'll chop up uh a win for uh
kamikaze knight
let's check out uh tom dear's game
he ended up losing that that
first game tom deers also with the
enterprise
neil got him in round one so let's see
what's going on here
it looks like neil is plus
one at the moment
but it is tom's turn and tom the theme
of the night has this uh
center center pawn so maybe he can march
into victory i would not march it just
yet
i might want to actually get behind the
pawn right now with a move like bishop
g2 here
just give it some more support and then
when the time's right
then march it down for victory so let's
see if
tom can play bishop g2 here and then
maybe get castle too
because it's kind of dangerous to have
your king in the center if i can somehow
get this pawn out of the way
you know bad things are going to happen
so okay queen up
i need to get now he gives him a check
so let's see how uh tom's gonna deal
with the check the king is in danger
right now so
so maybe queen back to d2
king the d1 or king to e2 look very
dangerous
and okay so maybe he'll castle like this
but that that might not work so we give
him another check
and uh that rook that rook is going to
be
be gone
so it looks like neil with express grips
might uh
might get them all right
10 john against 10 john is uh
playing with white 10 john plays for uh
which team does 10
10 john play for he's playing against
bio
fire proto and so this
bio proto plays for a bear here
so this is an extra game so ten john
most likely plays for uh
yeah he plays for edward jones
oh he's going for it they're going for
he was going for bishop takes f7 but uh
oh
hey ben simon oh never mind i got it all
right
so so okay so uh but uh but yeah
yeah uh bear bear is playing that they
want that extra 10 bonus points real bad
it looks like and
and they want first place as well and
they want to get right back into the uh
maybe work their way up into the uh
final four as we as we said at the
beginning of the broadcast
that uh worldwide technology which is
currently
in second place in the standings or
we're going into tonight
they they unfortunately did not bring
field a team tonight so uh
somebody else could easily easily jump
into uh
into second place overall in the grand
grand prix standings to make it to the
final four and vishal
vishal uh michelle with the win so he
finished
two-and-oh
on board two so edward jones got
a couple more wins here let's check back
in on uh
on jd he's bored one for edward jones
against nick ragone
board one for ascension jd is playing
with the white
pieces he got that uh nifty checkmate
with the
two rooks against the queen to to win
the first uh round but it looks like
it's
it's a pretty even match again
see what's really going on
but once again they got this uh
they got this the center passer
rick c7
okay so he's got two two players
attacking the b-pawn
the bishop and the rook and uh
how is he going to deal with this okay
so he
it's called interference that's
basically the uh the tactic
uh he got he got a guy so it's so now
this bishop is only attacking the
pawn through an x-ray so it's not really
oh but it was oh but he was it was a
dual threat huh
it was uh he was so concerned about the
b-pawn which i was too
hey well you gotta save one of them
so nick chose to to save uh
the b-pawn
queen takes back
very interesting all right let's see
what else is going on let's see what
uh alex is up to this was the game where
alex went on an all-out attack
at the very beginning on dave dave
managed to get his king all the way over
his castle king all the way over to to
look like he
he got castle long now
and uh it looks like alex is going to be
triumphant in this one
gives him a big check and that's going
to do it
alex gets another win for edward jones
so on the live tally right now
that i have is we have
edward jones with four points and
ascension with
one but that might not be
up to date we might we might have missed
a couple games but
but right now edward jones is up four to
one
and these are the standings going in to
round number two edward jones had the
lead with 31
enterprise right behind with 26. merits
had 24.
bear had 16 but they might as well be at
26 because they get that 10 points for
the buy
and ascension still was in it it still
could be in it
it's never over if you especially if
you're just down four to one
uh with 15. so they they could climb up
with that 20 uh with the 20 bonus points
they they could still theoretically get
get on the
board and uh and express grips is on the
board as well
so they no longer have the goose egg
so okay so let's get back to the uh pick
to the matches
orion chester club manager was able to
to win to win win for the chess club huh
and he won his first match against vindy
so we'll we'll give ryan a win
all right
all right so john boyer he did win that
first game
let's see if he did get to play his
alakins defense
he did not it looks like he transposed
oh no no he did
it was like that the computer just
doesn't know
the computer doesn't the computer thinks
they're playing the french defense
but no no he did start uh e4
and then john played his favorite knight
f6
all right and let's see how he's uh yes
i'm still here i'm still here i'm still
here
john is currently plus five but i guess
this rook is going away
but now he's got
he's attacking the queen and when the
queen moves
see ya rook
now we are getting some results in here
let's go back to uh moneyballin
his queen is attacked but he is plus one
money ballin is of course playing
for uh enterprise
some very competitive matches uh tonight
it's like it's good it's good to see
and these are all brand new matches as
well uh
these guys this is the third installment
of the corporate chess league so
they're all playing new opponents
hopefully uh
hopefully making some uh some new
contacts new friends and uh
chess is a great game competitive game
but in the end it's uh
it's just fun fun game all right
let's see who else we got going on
we did start about five minutes earlier
than uh schedule so
so we we might be uh we might be all
through
about eight o'clock tonight when it's
all said and done
as most of these games are on their uh
in the second round of
round two let's check back with john
he's plus three but this is very
dangerous
this guy would really love to get his
queen right there
on g7 for the for the checkmate
so let's see if he can figure it out and
now john has the uh
d-pawn passer here
is that that might be the difference in
this game
see what else is going on let's see uh
ryan chester
it's all tied at one in his game
king taker one three two four
that's tied up at four
and the difference between a pass pawn
and not a pass pawn if
if somehow as gilmore 999 could get uh
this pawn
out out of the way he'd have a pastor
but
he's just gonna he's just gonna
take it and call it a day i guess
he's just hoping that he doesn't capture
it that
that capture is not alive
but king taker should see
that he needs to take that pawn
this is the the actual live position
here
he's attacking the queen and the pawn
so the most natural thing is just to
take it however i guess he's thinking
i'm over one i guess he's thinking that
this b-pawn would fall then
if uh if that happened so he moves his
queen to d8 protecting the pawn
that way if uh if s gilmore takes it
queen will take on c7 and protect the uh
protect the pawn the bee pun that was
pretty nifty how he he got out of that
i thought it was just a natural take but
king taker's got some moves he's got
some moves now the knight's coming down
it's forking the
the queen and the pawn
so now the queen has got to move but
he's got to be careful if he plays his
queen to c8
guess what i got the check and the fork
coming up so uh
got to be careful got to be careful when
you're playing playing chess here
it's a thinking man's game that's for
sure
so queen back to d8 but now this is
going to be
it's going to be dangerous because
knight takes
oh wait a minute
who knight takes pawn looks looks
pretty promising for uh s gilmore s
gilmore is playing for
uh ascension edward jones uh
player is king taker one three
one three two four and there we go we
take here
and now we're bearing down on this
bishop here
and all these rooks are hanging so he's
almost got to play rook takes rook here
i don't know what else you can do
desperate times oh you can play rook
takes rook
and then after pawn takes rook maybe
play rook to f7
oh he played rook takes b6 i i
i incorrectly guessed so this is the
live position
knight takes b6
may have been more promising but but
maybe not because
it it it looks kind of tricky with these
rooks on the same
uh same file so maybe you didn't want to
go into that line
see let's see what else is going on here
this looks like a pretty exciting game
let's see what what moneyballin is all
up to here
so he's got the well he's got the two
rooks in the bishop
but his opponent playing for express
scripts has
a queen a rook and a bishop
so he's got to pull something out quick
he wants to hang on
another check here
blocks the check oh so queen to g7 is
going to be deadly
because
it's not going to be checkmate yet can
we find the mate
i cannot d4 is not checkmate
ooh yeah yeah that's what i wanted to
play
and i think rick to here is all she
wrote
all right he's still he's still hanging
on by a thread here
no reason to give up especially if if if
you can get rid of this pawn
there's a term in chess called the angry
rook if this king is somehow stalemated
down here like in the corner
and can't move uh
you could just try to like do all these
reckless checks and then if the king
ever takes your rook
guess what stalemate draw so
it's never over he just needs to get rid
of mary ball
needs to get rid of this pawn asap to
and try to achieve the stalemate
position
oh he's got a big discovered check here
let's see if he plays it
oh he's just going to march the center
point of victory all right
money ballin's taking my advice he's
getting rid of that pawn trying for that
angry rook
all right let's see if the angry rook
can prevail
and every point every point counts in
the uh
corporate chess league because i mean
this half point if if
money balling would somehow get it would
uh carry over uh
into the final four grand prix standings
here so
every point counts you got to get that
king in the corner moneyball and got to
get that king in the corner oh there
goes the rook
so he is he is playing for a stalemate
here that's why you never give up in
chess but
this looks like a
pretty quick checkmate here
let's see if he can play queen queen to
there is going to be checkmate here
let's see if we can play it
all right okay but now he's got the he's
got the cool position
and then he can just
so so that's another win for uh
express scripts so they they now have at
least three points
and they're let's see what uh
well let's go back to king taker's game
wow a lot the stuff is going on here
like look at this this rook is hanging
this bishop is hanging this knight is
hanging
and they had dreams of discovered checks
oh he's got a discovered check here
where he plays check
okay and then king takes and then this
queen swoops down for the checkmate
oh oh and this is going to get good
so do not take this rook
maybe he can try some interference here
i don't know this is this
is this is edge of your seat type stuff
so bishop the g8 threatens mate in
two what are you gonna do
about it what are you gonna do about it
king taker
oh and all right queen
queen to g5
threatening your own checkmate i mean if
you don't see my maiden two
guess what i'm just gonna checkmate you
desperate times
oh i think i saw a way he could have
actually got out of it
he could have played that interference
move e4 maybe
rick the g6 uh protects the checkmate
through an x-ray here
yeah maybe hey ben simon do you have uh
access to the uh live scores in the uh
in the uh edward jones ascension match
is is nicholas is he updating those
give a big shout out to our uh talking
about the individual
yeah yeah what's the score in that uh
edward jones against ascension
because i the last time we checked it
was
i had it four to one edward jones
ben simon is updating the scores
four five six i can't so that's six the
what
is six to one i i can't see the uh
i can't see the uh is it six to one
right now
we're trying to get the uh the scores on
the screen for you
but like i said every point counts in
the long run
so this is especially edward jones
they want to they want to be
number one when it's all said and done
so yeah we have uh
we have it six to one right now but as i
said
so it looks like edward jones is
probably going to hold on
to win regardless
but every point counts because we'll see
we'll tally up the scores uh momentarily
once once this game has concluded
and ryan chester is still uh
still playing against uh a player from
uh
from bear i believe oh yeah definitely
he's playing vindy so we'll check on
that one at the
exciting conclusion of a king taker's
game
so let's see what is going on so the
time pressure is a big
factor in the corporate chess league you
get you just get that base time of 10
minutes
no delay no increment so anything can
happen in these games you could you
could miss a checkmate you could miss a
mate in two
you could miss them made in five you can
miss
a fork it's it's tough especially when
the pressure's on playing in team events
is uh is rewarding and nerve-wracking
i've been there i
was fortunate enough to play for uh
bishop the berg's chess team
for uh three years in the 90s and helped
us uh
helped us get some glory so it was a lot
of fun
so let's check it out
rick to h6 this
so it's a black to move here
king takers move 90 seconds he's in the
danger zone
and uh he can take this rook but maybe
he doesn't want to yet
but but by taking the rook oh if queen
takes back you have queen takes f2
check king has to move queen to f1 check
queen takes queen rook takes and
checkmate so he cannot take
this bishop back because he will get
checkmated
so oh oh he needs oh
this is desperate times for uh
oh i guess that's uh steve steve gilmore
999 he needs to do this discovered
check and maybe he still has got the
back he's still got the checkmate back
so if he plays here he's gonna get
checkmated oh this is
this is too good to be true everybody
wants that checkmate
who is gonna get it oh
let's see
can he can he get it can he get it
because even if he doesn't take if he
even plays king to g7 it's the same
thing
checkmate oh
oh you retreated he retreated but
unfortunately that's not going to get
him the checkmate
so he's got to get his king out of dodge
but it's still anybody's game because
they're under a minute left
and uh exciting stuff here in the
corporate chess league
to finish off put a put a big bow on the
night
a very successful night for the
corporate chess league
we'll get done before eight o'clock and
so we got it in within the two hour time
span
that's always a good thing it doesn't
seem like there was many glitches
tonight shout out to uh to nick risco
and
all the uh all the uh participants for
for making the the event run uh smooth
as well
win or lose hopefully everybody's went
home happy
so let's check this out oh and vindi got
his revenge on club
manager ryan chester
another point for bear maybe we'll have
to see uh when it all
when all the points are tabulated by
nicolas wisco uh if
bear did get that extra bonus 10 points
for the for the win
both players under a minute now
and now king the g8
so king taker is still threatening the
checkmate in
two moves which is even simpler now uh
queen takes f2 check
all right so he gives him a check
wait you have to check i mean you cannot
take this bishop or else you get
checkmated
so he blocks with the knight
where did that knight come from the
knight came from the uh from the edge of
the board
so what what can we get what can we get
oh i got the top guesser one out of four
one out of four not too bad
all right so he stops the mate in uh two
very good
very good just keep the pressure on 14
seconds
see we'll see what's going on here
33 seconds and there's no checkmate
so so just move the queen somewhere
just all right he moves it he's
attacking the rook but it is protected
by the bishop and the queen
big check big check
can six seconds five seconds gotta make
a move any move just
take the night just hope something works
oh
but king taker takes it another point
for edward jones
so edward jones finished with uh
they won that match seven to one
according to uh
according to my account uh nicholas
risco is probably uh
typing away and tabulate all the scores
i do not want to say any final scores
until uh
until he says uh until he's done
ultimately updating
all right we got some shout outs too
nicholas risco i started updating the
scoreboard for round two results
okay great
thank you uh teacher man 22.
uh it it really is quite an endeavor to
put this uh corporate chess league on
and well i mean we miss having it live
obviously
at the club where we can eat drink
socialize
pass out business cards and and just
have fun and
be with your colleagues and make
connections
and have fun but hopefully we'll be back
sometime in 2020 and uh
but it's it's it's still it was still a
heck of a time
maybe we'll take a quick commercial
break and we'll be back with the final
final standings
that sound good ben simon all right
see you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
since 2009 our mission has always been
to teach and promote the value chess
brings to our community in these times
of social distancing it's more important
than ever
that we stay connected to carry on that
mission we are currently offering 24
weekly classes online
through our youtube and twitch channels
we're also holding tournaments and
private lessons online
from the comfort of their own home
students can enjoy all the benefits of
our scholastic chess initiative digital
our scholastic outreach continues with
virtual chess classrooms
scholastic tournaments and scouts bsa
merit badge workshops
on behalf of everyone at the saint louis
chess club we hope you and your loved
ones stay safe and continue to watch
play and enjoy the game of chess
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
do
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back one and all uh we do have
the the final standings
and i did some quick tabulations to get
everybody's uh final four grand prix
points
so i do have some good news for uh for
uh for a team
for a couple teams actually okay so
edward jones is victorious tonight in
the third installment of the corporate
chess league they scored 65 points
merits came in second with uh 49 points
congratulations enterprise
got on the metal board with 40 points
bear 30 ascension 16
express scripts 10 and doherty one now i
do have
unofficial grand prix final four
standings of course
if you want to get into the final four
uh
because you gotta you gotta outscore
everybody
and finished in the top four okay so
here we go and that will be december
17th
uh so this is unofficial but we have
edward jones with 188
and a half merits
faulting into the number two position
with 101 points
worldwide technology only fell one spot
by not participating tonight
uh they uh they're in third with 83
and now the drum roll who has that
mystery fourth spot all right
this is unofficial but it looks like
enterprise
is back in the final four if it started
today with 78.5 points
uh right behind is ascension with 72 and
a half
uh bear has 68 and express scripts right
on their heels with 59 as well
and uh doherty has 18 and a half grand
three points
so uh join us next month hopefully
you'll get
you see more people edward jones brings
a lot more players
and they have a lot more opportunities
to score a lot more points
so so if you know a a colleague
in your business that uh is a chess
player
you know bring them along the more the
merrier and we'll happy to have it
it'll be uh next month in september for
the fourth installment of the
corporate chess league cheers everybody
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello welcome back everybody i have
decided the best game
and it was the best game is not always
the best game but sometimes it's the
most exciting fun
and uh it's basically uh what the
corporate chess league is all about and
it was definitely
the last game we saw uh king taker one
three
two four against uh mr gilmore
and uh it was a big finish
and uh and it was a
it was a heck of a game and uh so
congratulations uh
king taker1324 mr
justin beckstead you will be getting
some chess club goodies all right
until next time this is michael j hummer
signing off good night
you